If you've got a Bible with you,
do please turn with me once again
to Ephesians chapter one.
Ephesians chapter one.
As you're turning there,
we've seen already that the Apostle Paul's ministry
was marked by praise and prayer really.
You see that in Ephesians here at the start.
He's beginning with this prayer of praise
that we've been looking at over the past couple of weeks.
He's praising God for every spiritual blessing
that is ours in Christ.
And he now moves from praise to a prayer of intercession.
He's praying for the Ephesians,
and those who will receive this letter.
And he lets them know that he's praying for them.
And he doesn't just let them know that
he's praying for them,
he lets them know what he is praying for them as well.
And so that's what we're reading about.
His prayer for them as we come to Ephesians
chapter one verses 15 down to the end of verse 23.
It says, for this reason,
because I have heard of your faith in the Lord Jesus
and your love toward all the saints,
I do not cease to give thanks for you,
remembering you in my prayers,
that the God of our Lord Jesus Christ,
the Father of glory,
may give you the spirit of wisdom
and of revelation in the knowledge of him.
Having the eyes of your hearts enlightened
that you may know what is the hope
to which he has called you.
What are the riches of his glorious inheritance in the saints?
And what is the immeasurable greatness
of his power toward us who believe?
According to the working of his great might
that he worked in Christ when he raised him from the dead
and seated him at the right hand in the heavenly places,
far above all rule and authority and power and dominion
and above every name that is named.
Not only in this age, but also in the one to come.
And he put all things under his feet
and gave him as head over all things to the church,
which is his body, the fullness of him who fills all in all.
This is the word of the Lord.
Let's pray once again.
Lord, as we come now to your word,
I pray that you would by your spirit open our eyes
that we may see wondrous things here.
Would I pray that you would fill us
with a desire to know them and the faith to believe in them?
Lord, I pray that as we see them
that you would change us through them.
Would open our eyes to see more of you we pray
in Jesus' name, amen.
Just over 18 years ago now,
I went to England for the very first time.
And when I was there,
I met the most beautiful girl I'd ever seen
in Stoke-on-Trents.
I remember the day vividly.
I walked into the city center.
We were going to this event and there was Julia.
She was blonde hair and white top and yellow skirt.
And she has very little recollection of the day at all.
But I remember her stood there and I met her.
And so that was day one of when we met.
And then a few weeks ago,
we were kind of giving this little exercise
to work through together.
And the exercise was this,
go away for 10 or 15 minutes
and find out something that you do not know about your spouse.
And at the start, it was kind of hard to like,
okay, what do we actually not know?
But after you start thinking and talking,
you realize that even now,
there are still things about each other to discover.
Well, the focal point of what Paul is praying here
is that the Ephesians might know him.
It's the knowledge of him he's praying about
at the end of verse 17.
The reason why I mentioned Julia and getting to know her
is to point out a couple of things about the knowledge
that Paul speaks about at the end of verse 17
where he talks about the knowledge of him.
First of all, the knowledge is personal.
So it's not so much about knowing something
as it is someone.
So it's not like, I don't know,
reading a Wikipedia entry.
You know, it's getting to know somebody.
So I think about like when Julia and I
were first in contact with each other,
we were in different parts of the world.
So there were a lot of emails exchanged.
Let me tell you, I didn't read those emails
like a Wikipedia entry.
You know, there was a personal dynamic to it.
That was different.
And it's interesting, when you look at knowledge
across Scripture, this word knowing,
it is actually a word that is used to refer
to the relationship of a husband and a wife.
It is an intimate knowledge that is here.
So it's personal, but it's also progressive.
So you can know and love someone for years
and still have more to discover about them.
So here Paul is writing to people
who have already come to know the Lord
and yet he's praying that they might know him.
In other words, he's praying that they might know him more.
So whether you've known him for five minutes
or for 50 years, you're still just scratching
at the surface.
There's more to know when you know the Lord.
So it's personal and progressive.
So this is the main point of Paul's letter, rather,
that Christians might come to know God better.
This is what he is praying here for them.
So as we get started looking at this together,
just a couple of personal questions.
One is, do you know God?
Not just do you know things about God?
Do you know the Lord personally?
The second question is, are you growing
in your knowledge of him?
Do you want to know him more?
Can you see that you're growing in your knowledge of him?
Well, what Paul is praying here, what he writes here,
helps us with this.
And so we're gonna look at what he prays
by dividing it up into three questions.
There's three questions you came,
not knowing you were gonna ask me this morning.
But these are the questions you're gonna ask.
We're gonna ask this of the text really together.
And here's the three questions.
I'll go ahead and tell you what they are.
One is, how can we know that we know God?
The second question is, how can we grow
in the knowledge of God?
And the third question we're gonna ask is,
well, what are some examples of what that looks like?
Okay, so what are some examples?
So first of all, how can we know that we know God?
Well, verse 15, right at the start
of Paul telling them he's praying,
he tells them that he is certain
that they are essentially real Christians.
He knows that they are true believers.
He's not met all of them personally,
but from what he has heard about them,
he has been convinced that they really know the Lord.
And so this is the reason why he is praying for them,
he writes.
So what convinces him that they truly know the Lord?
What is the evidence that demonstrates
somebody really knows God?
What would be the evidence that would come through
in our lives?
What's two things?
One is faith, and the other is love.
So you got faith and love here together.
So you got a vertical one, faith in the Lord Jesus Christ.
He says, I've heard about that.
And the other is horizontal,
and your love for all the saints.
And both are crucially important
when it comes to knowing whether or not you know the Lord.
So let's just take him one at a time.
He's heard about their faith in the Lord Jesus.
So if you were to ask Paul a question like this,
what must someone believe in order to be saved?
His answer would be simple.
Well, they must believe on the Lord Jesus Christ.
You see that here in the text,
but you also see it in other places.
You go back to Acts chapter 16,
and you've got the interaction with the Philippian jailer.
And the jailer asked Paul and Silas,
sirs, what must I do to be saved?
Acts 16, 31, the answer comes back.
Believe on the Lord Jesus Christ,
and you will be saved.
And he goes on to explain further about who Jesus is.
But note the simplicity of that.
Believe on Jesus, and you'll be saved.
Well, we might say, well, there is a lot more to this
than just that.
I mean, think about all the doctrines
we need to cover with people.
Like there's like the inspiration of Scripture,
and we could go on and on listing
all of these important doctrines,
and they all are all important.
Every doctrine is important
if it's coming from Scripture.
And the fact is, as people grow in Christ,
they will believe what Scripture says about Him
in more depth.
But we think of a new believer,
like a baby doesn't know much
and can't articulate much about his mother,
but the baby knows who his mother is.
There is a relationship there,
and as the child grows,
their knowledge grows as well.
So everything begins with our faith in Jesus Christ.
We're saved through faith in Him
by trusting in Jesus and Him alone
as our Savior and as our King.
And as we grow, we learn more,
but we continue to trust in Him and in Him alone.
So the answer to whether or not you know God
is found in what you're putting your trust in,
or are you putting your trust in Jesus?
Not in your works, not in some system,
not in how much you know or how much you do,
is your trust in Jesus and Him alone to save you.
And there's another piece of evidence here
that demonstrates someone that someone truly knows the Lord,
and that is love for all the saints.
He says, I've heard about your faith in the Lord Jesus
and your love towards all the saints.
So one of the ways you can see
that someone knows the Lord is in their love for others,
particularly their brothers and sisters in Christ.
Just be clear, it isn't our love for God
or for others that saves us, it is His love for us.
But when you come to know His love in Jesus,
it changes the way you see and treat others.
So 1 John chapter four, verses seven and eight,
the apostle John says it very clearly here,
beloved, let us love one another,
for love is from God,
and everyone who loves has been born of God
and knows God.
Anyone who does not love does not know God
because God is love.
So love shows that we truly know the Lord because He is love.
So here, Paul is even more assured though,
he says that he could see that love there,
but there's an even extra layer of assurance
because they have love for all the saints.
You see, anybody in the world can love people
that they would naturally get along with.
They can love their family, they can love their friends,
but it takes a supernatural love
that would draw us towards those
we would naturally want to avoid.
So there's a love for all the saints,
not just the ones I would naturally get along with.
That's evidence of the love of God,
the God who loves sinners that we love all the saints.
So faith and love together.
And it's important before we move on
that we hold these two truths together simultaneously.
And if you hold both of those together,
you might counter then some of the lies you hear
you might notice some of the lies you hear.
So one of them say in relation to faith,
you might hear somebody say it,
I've had this said to me in conversation before,
well, you know, we all believe different things,
different religions of the world all believe different things,
but at the end of the day,
what really matters is how we treat one another.
And I see that the sentiment of love
in what they're saying there, but are they right?
God makes it clear that what we believe really matters.
Like it really matters what your faith in.
Like your eternity is resting on something.
And I hope it is not resting on
how well you treat other people.
I hope my eternity isn't resting in that it isn't.
It's through faith in Jesus that matters.
But also that's not to say that our works do not matter
or that our love for others don't matter.
So on the flip side, you might have someone who says,
you know, that they really feel justified
in treating other people harshly.
Because what really matters is believing the right things.
Like they're looking, they might want to,
they're really boastful in what they believe
and they're just looking to destroy other people
with the arguments that they make towards them.
And there's a really harsh spirit towards other people.
But here we see that knowing God is seen in our love for others
as well as in what we believe about God.
So I don't mean that if you sin, you're definitely not saved.
But if you say, Jesus is my king,
then surely something should be seen of following him.
Something of his love should be coming through in your life.
If that's not the case, it's not saying,
well, you definitely don't know him,
but your grounds for assurance that you know him
are really shaky.
So put your faith in Jesus.
So that's how we know that we know him.
My trusting in Jesus.
And that's evidence in our love for others.
So how do we then grow in the knowledge of God?
This is what Paul's really praying for here.
So we get the answer by looking at the specific ways
that he prays that they might grow
in the knowledge of God.
So let's walk through those together.
So there's a receiving element
and there's a pursuing element.
So let's look at the receiving element first.
So he's praying that they might be,
you see it in verse 17,
that the God of our Lord Jesus Christ,
the Father of glory may give you the spirit of wisdom
and of revelation in the knowledge of him.
So here's how we grow in the knowledge of God
by being given the spirit.
God gives us his spirit.
So you might say, well, hang on a second.
Over the last couple of weeks,
we've seen that everyone who believes in Christ
is sealed with the Holy Spirit.
And that's absolutely true.
You go back in verse 13,
you see that we're given the Holy Spirit when we believe.
That's right.
So what is Paul saying here
that we're given the spirit then after that?
What's going on here?
What he's talking about is knowing the work
of the spirit in increasing measure.
That's what he's been talking about
when he talks about being given the spirit of wisdom
and revelation, knowing the work of the spirit
in increasing measure because you cannot separate
the person of the Holy Spirit
and the work of the Holy Spirit.
So we're knowing his work more.
So in other words, he's praying that the spirit of God
would make more and more of God known to them
as he works in their lives.
So God is personally making himself known to us
by the spirit.
So when we have scripture here in front of us,
for example, God doesn't just give us a book
and then kind of send us off on our own to say,
well, this is what shows,
the Bible shows what I'm like.
It's over to you to figure that out.
Like it's true that this tells us
what God is like truly,
but God personally comes to us in the work of his spirit
and shows us the truth that he tells us about
in his word.
It's his very present and work
that causes us to grow in knowledge.
So we can't understand spiritual truth on our own.
So if you go back to 1 Corinthians in chapter two,
verses six to 16,
I wish we could kind of walk through all of that together
because this deals with this at length really.
There Paul is essentially talking about
how we cannot figure out spiritual truths
by mere natural wisdom.
They must be taught to us by the spirit of God.
Who better to tell us the mind of God
than God himself by his spirit?
So we've got to be taught by the spirit.
They have to be revealed to us by the spirit.
It's like the lights are out
when it comes to just our natural mind, our natural man.
And they have to be turned on for us to see these truths.
How are they turned on by the work of the spirit?
And so that's what we see here.
So to be given the spirit is to
have the eyes of our hearts enlightened.
Do you see that in verse 18?
Having the eyes of your hearts enlightened
that you may know.
So Paul's there.
What does that mean?
To have the eyes of our hearts enlightened.
What a strange phrase to mix eyes and hearts together.
What's going on here?
Well, let's just separate those out.
So biblically speaking,
the heart is the center of your being,
the center of who you are.
It includes both your mind and your emotions.
Okay, so take that.
Then we say then to have the eyes of your heart enlightened
is to see something both truly and experientially.
Right, so if the heart involves both the mind and the emotions
to have the eyes of our hearts enlightened
is to see something, to know something truly
and experientially.
There's no better way to illustrate this
than biscuits and gravy.
No, I'm sure there's much better ways.
I was, so when I was in England,
people said often to me like,
hey, what kind of food do you miss back in the States?
And first thing that we call this kind of in my mind
is biscuits, we'll start there.
And I said, you know, the best way to have biscuits
is with gravy.
And you can imagine your kind of average Brit hearing that.
First of all, biscuits is a cookie.
And then gravy is a kind of brown gravy
that you might put on turkey or something.
And they said to have biscuits and gravy.
But generally speaking, most people know,
apart from like children,
that you're talking about something different.
And so if you're over there
and you're explaining biscuits and gravy,
how would you explain it to somebody?
What is a biscuit to somebody who's never seen one before
or tasted one before?
I mean, I kind of thought of, it's kind of like a scone,
but it's not sweet and it's not exactly like a scone.
And you try to explain it.
And gravy, well, it's like that,
but it's kind of like white gravy,
but it's got sausage and it's got a bit of,
it still doesn't do justice to what you're trying to say.
But we had some visitors come to see us
a couple months ago from the UK,
and I was finally able to truly explain it.
So I was like, you've got to have biscuits and gravy
while you're here.
And the best way for me to, I can explain it to you,
but the best way for you to know what it is
is to just taste it, to taste it.
All right, so there's a knowledge part of it
and there's an experience part of it.
All right, so to have the eyes of your heart enlightened
is to know God truly, like these facts about Him,
but also experientially to be drawn into the reality
of what that truth is saying.
It is tasting and seeing that the Lord is good.
So knowing God involves our understanding, yes,
but it also involves our affections.
It is rational and it is also emotional.
There is light and there is heat.
So it's something that we receive,
but it's also something we pursue.
So God is the one who gives us the knowledge of Him.
He's the one who comes to us in the work of His Spirit.
But we're called to pursue this knowledge too.
You see this all the way throughout Scripture.
So Hosea chapter six, verse three, wonderful verse,
simple verse, it says, let us know,
let us pursue the knowledge of the Lord.
It's the same kind of knowledge being spoken of here.
You see this right the way throughout the Psalms,
I mean you can just name Psalm after Psalm,
but Psalm 27 says this,
one thing have I asked the Lord
and that will I seek after,
that I may dwell in the house of the Lord
all the days of my life to gaze upon the beauty of the Lord
and to inquire in His temple.
You have said, seek my face.
My heart says to you, your face, oh Lord, do I seek?
He's seeking after the knowledge of God in prayer,
gazing upon His beauty.
You see this in Philippians chapter three in verse eight
and Paul is giving his testimony, telling his story
and he says this, he says, I count everything as loss
compared to the surpassing worth of knowing Christ.
And then he says, for his sake I've suffered the loss
of all things and count them as rubbish
in order that I may gain Christ.
He goes on to talk about continuing
in that pursuit of the Lord.
Fact is the greatest pursuit in life is the pursuit of God.
It's what we're called to devote our lives to really.
So where do we see that here in the text?
Well it's kind of implicit here.
Let's see it this way.
Paul is writing about these specific truths
that are revealed by the spirit
and he's also praying for their knowledge of the Lord.
So to say that knowledge of the Lord
is something that is given,
isn't to say we just passively sit back
and kind of wait for it to mystically happen to us.
Paul wants them to know some things about the Lord as well
and he's praying as well.
So he's involved in this whole process of them
knowing the Lord in his prayer.
So what does the pursuit look like for us?
It looks like us being driven to what is written
in his word that we may know more about him.
It's here that we find out about his attributes
and his ways.
It is here that we see his glory displayed.
So this is what pursuit of God looks like,
wanting to know him in his word.
It also looks like prayer.
As we see more about him,
it leads us to praise and prayer
like we see the apostle Paul demonstrating here.
It's coming to this God himself.
It's a personal relationship remember.
And notice as well that he's writing to fellow believers.
This letter is being read in the life of a church.
We pursue the Lord together.
This involves our kind of personal quiet time with the Lord
but it's also a collective pursuit.
We need to hear one another speaking the truth of God
to each other.
We need to pray for one another.
So a church that is centered on the word of God
and when it says about him in a church
that is praying for one another
and seeking after God in that way
is a church that will be growing
in the knowledge of the Lord together.
So we don't do these things out of a sense of guilt.
Like I've got to read my Bible.
I haven't prayed for a while so I really should pray.
It's wanting to know him that drives us.
It's the pursuit of God.
So what might this look like practically?
Well Paul gives us then three examples
of what this sort of looks like.
All right so in practice like what does it look like
to be pursuing the knowledge of God
to have the eyes of our hearts enlightened by the spirit.
So the three things that Paul says we'll know
as the spirit enlightens the eyes of our hearts
as he draws us further into the knowledge of God.
First of all he talks about the hope of his calling.
There in verse 18,
from the eyes of our hearts are enlightened
we know what is the hope to which he has called you.
Literally the hope of his calling.
So what is his calling?
In some ways when he talks about the calling here
it's a one word summary of everything he was praising God
for that we've looked at the past couple weeks together.
He's praising God or he's talking about us knowing
the calling or us knowing the initiative
that God took to make us his own.
That's his calling.
It's when you became a Christian if you know the Lord.
So if you're a true believer it's because God
called you to himself.
Do we call upon the Lord?
Yes whoever calls upon the name of the Lord will be saved.
But we call upon the Lord because he calls us.
And his calling is part of an unbroken chain
that begins before the foundation of the world.
You see that in Ephesians one
but there's a great verse Romans 8 30
that summarizes this.
You see this sort of unbroken chain
in what Paul writes there.
He says, and those whom he predestined,
he also called.
And those whom he called, he also justified.
And those whom he justified, he also glorified.
Right, so there's a hope to be had in his calling.
Right, so the certainty of his effectual call
gives us hope.
So the hope being spoken of here
isn't it kind of like an uncertain wish?
Like I really hope we have some good weather here next week.
It's not that, it's a definite assurance.
I can know that I belong to the Lord
and will one day be with him
because he called me.
He made me his own.
Okay, so the spirit of God assures our hearts
by opening our eyes to see the certainty
of the fact that God has called us.
But also what's another thing
that the spirit opens our eyes to?
The glory of his inheritance.
So the hope to which he's called you.
And then also in verse 18, there at the end,
what are the riches of his glorious inheritance
in the saints?
So notice there that he isn't talking about our inheritance.
You might read it in that way.
He's talking about the inheritance that is coming to us.
Like he spoke about that before
and we looked at that before.
He's talking about God's inheritance.
So he wants us to know God's inheritance.
Well, what is that?
What does he want us to know here?
And we might think well,
what riches could God possibly inherit?
I mean think of, I don't know, Elon Musk.
Right, say you strike up a friendship with your buddy Elon
and it's come time for his birthday
and you wanna really buy him something.
But what can you buy the richest man in the world
that he really needs?
Like, what is it that he would really treasure and say,
I've always wanted this.
I wasn't able to get this.
I've finally able to have this.
Be a really hard person to buy for.
Somebody who has everything.
Over the past couple of weeks,
we've seen God's absolute sovereignty.
Right, he's over everything.
He can have whatever he wants.
And yet we're told here that there is a treasure
that he just can't wait to receive.
There are some riches that he has his eyes on.
What are these riches?
What is his inheritance?
Is this wonderful?
It's us.
His inheritance is in the saints.
We are the ones he is waiting on.
He is looking forward to the day
when he gathers the people he has made perfect
through Christ.
We are his treasured inheritance.
I mean that might make you uncomfortable
to think of God thinking of you in that way
but he absolutely does.
Either you look back in the Old Testament,
Zechariah chapter three verse 17,
it speaks about the Lord rejoicing
over his people with gladness.
That is how the Lord looks upon us.
Christian, God absolutely treasures you.
You are treasured.
You are more loved than you can possibly imagine.
And one of the things that God wants to do
in your life through his spirit
is to draw you into that reality,
to experience more of his great love for you.
To not just know it intellectually in your mind
but to know it in your heart of hearts
that you are loved by God.
It's been compared before to like a father
walking down the road with his daughter
and as they're walking down the road
he says to her, I love you.
And the daughter believes what he says
but then a moment later he says, I really love you.
And he picks up his daughter and he swings her around
and their eyed eyes and he swings around.
He draws her in close and gives her this big hug.
That's the work of the spirit being spoken of here.
So God is making it known that he loves us.
We are in his inheritance and the spirit
draws us into that reality.
He drives home the truth that we are loved by God.
But also thirdly see this.
We know the hope of his calling,
that we are in his inheritance.
We also know the power of his might.
Verses 19 to 23.
The apostle Paul is praying that they might know
God's great power.
What is the immeasurable greatness of his power
towards us who believe according to the working
of his great might?
A couple of weeks ago I watched a video
of the eruption of Mount St. Helens.
It was really unbelievable to watch it.
It was unreal just seeing this mountain
just begin to crumble.
You know it was considered to be the most powerful
volcanic eruption in US history.
The blast force equivalent was that of 10 to 50 megatons
of TNT.
It demolished the northern side of the volcano
and sent a massive ash cloud up into the air
over 80,000 feet.
Hard to imagine.
In a matter of minutes over 230 square miles
were destroyed and it permanently altered
the mountain's shape.
It reduced its height by at least 1,300 feet.
So powerful.
And yet here's the thing about that blast.
Its power was measurable.
We can give the statistics,
we can talk through the numbers.
It's measurable.
But notice how God's power is described in verse 19.
It's immeasurable.
It's beyond knowing.
His power is limitless.
He's the creator and sustainer of all things.
And so his power surpasses every earthly power.
No matter Jeremiah said,
Lord God it is you who has made the heavens
and the earth by your great power
and by your outstretched arm.
Nothing is too hard for you.
And that power is displayed in creation.
But there's a particular demonstration of power
that Paul wants us to see here.
It's the power that he has shown in Christ.
Notice verse 19, it speaks of the working of his great might
that he worked in Christ when?
When he raised him from the dead
and seated him at his right hand in the heavenly places.
So God's power is demonstrated in Christ.
It's demonstrated in his resurrection.
So it was God's power that reached into the tomb
and raised Jesus' lifeless body from the dead
to live forevermore.
But it doesn't stop there.
You see God's power when Jesus is raised
to his heavenly throne.
When it speaks about this, about his ascension here,
it's not so much about a place
so much as it is a position of power and authority
because it's here in verse 21 we see
that he reigns far above all rule and authority
and power and dominion and over every name that is named
not only in this age but also in the one to come.
So maybe I don't know, imagine in your mind's eye
if you can a hierarchy of all the powers
in the world that have ever been.
Maybe the greatest rulers, both famous and infamous
and all the military might that goes behind that
stack them up.
And maybe above and beyond that the greatest powers
in the natural world, in the universe.
And then maybe think about all the spiritual powers
that you could possibly imagine.
And when we read that Jesus ascends
to his heavenly throne, he's being raised above
all power, all power that exists.
His power will never be exceeded.
He reigns today from the highest seat of authority
and he will never be dethroned.
One day the king who reigns in power
will bring evil to its final end
and every tongue will confess that he is Lord.
But notice also in verses 22 and 23 as we finish
that Jesus, this Jesus who's writing in power,
this power that we experience in him
is reigning over his church.
He's the head of the church.
What describes his authority, not just over creation
but the church, but it also shows that we are
inextricably and organically linked with him.
Say he's our head and we are his body.
Right, just like a head is linked to a body.
So we are linked to him.
And his glory fills the church
as we are directed and enabled
by the power of his risen life.
Right, so this God raises Jesus from the dead,
seats him on his heavenly throne
and we are his body in the world
and we are empowered and enabled to live for his glory
by the power of his risen life.
This is the power that the spirit makes known in us.
So think of his resurrection.
We can't defeat death.
But we've seen God's power can defeat it.
And so this same God who raised Jesus from the dead
in him and by his spirit reaches down
to people who are dead in their sins
and gives them new life in Jesus
by the power of his spirit.
He can raise us from the dead and make us new.
Think about his ascension
and how one day he's gonna bring all evil to an end
and he's gonna be recognized as Lord.
We cannot defeat evil by our power, no way.
But God can.
And the same God who raised Jesus to his heavenly throne
enables us by his spirit to say no to sin
and to say yes to righteousness.
This same God, Philippians chapter two verse 13 says
is at work in you, both to desire and to do
that which is pleasing to him.
So think of it.
The God who reigns in power over all things
is at work in you.
And it's only the spirit of God
that can cause you to know that power,
not just here in your head but in your heart
and to live according to that power.
So ask again what I asked at the start.
Do you know him?
Do you want to know him more?
Do you want to want to know him more?
I know I do and I pray you do as well.
So may God by the power of his spirit
open the eyes of our hearts that we may know him.
We might see and savor his calling, his love
and live according to his power.
So let's pray together.